this video was made possible by class -
central.com forward slash Pakman where
you can find thousands of top-rated
college lecturers on everything from
politics to science to business click
the link under this video to find out
more let's talk about one of the most
fascinating yet frustrating
pseudo-sciences out there which has
actually seen a huge revival over the
past few years attempt to prove that the
earth is flat you have to consider that
many of the people making videos arguing
that the earth is flat are probably
trolling or maybe even just trying to
make money through YouTube ads but sadly
enough plenty of people believe that the
earth is actually flat there are records
of the ancient Egyptians Mesopotamians
and Israelites describing the earth as a
flat disk floating in an ocean
ancient Chinese dynasties believed that
the earth was flat and square the
earliest documented speculations of
earth being spherical date back to Greek
philosophy around 6th century BC but
physical evidence wasn't offered until a
few centuries later for instance
Aristotle wrote in 4th century BC that
the earth must be a sphere because of
the Earth's curved shadow on the moon
and because of the different positions
of constellations based on the observers
geographical location later Greek
astronomer Eratosthenes concurred
pointing out that during the summer
solstice the Sun was in different
positions depending on the location of
the observer many sailors during that
time made the same assumption about
earth being a globe based on their
observations of the horizon a spherical
earth eventually became a given in
ancient Greek astronomy and the Roman
Empire helped spread the concept all
over the globe until it became the
adopted view of virtually all major
Western astronomical traditions so it's
a myth that Christopher Columbus's
voyage to the new world is what first
established a spherical earth it had
already been widely accepted for over a
thousand years an Earth's sphere shape
was first directly demonstrated by
Portuguese explorer Ferdinand Magellan
in 1519 when
he captain the first expedition to
circumnavigate the globe this
circumnavigation combined with
trigonometry invented by the Greeks 1700
years prior eliminated any ambiguity
that the earth was a sphere tiny groups
of flat earthers have always existed in
certain religious communities but Flat
Earth theories have seen a huge
resurgence since the dawn of the
internet especially over the last five
years the most popular modern theory
from flat earthers is that the earth is
a flat round disc where the North Pole
is in the center with the continents
around it and that Antarctica makes up
the outside of the disc which serves as
a sort of giant circular ice wall that
holds the oceans in place keeping the
water from spilling off the edge one of
the many issues would be that regardless
of what shape the earth is even if it
was a flat disc gravity would always be
pulling objects towards the center of
the disc so as you move towards the
outside of the disc gravity isn't going
to be pulling you down towards the
ground it's going to pull you back
towards the middle of the disk so if you
were and say the southernmost part of
South America maybe in my home country
of Argentina you would start sliding
back towards the North Pole and of
course this is not what happens but the
natural response from many flat earthers
is gravity simply isn't real many will
tell you that the earth is flying upward
through space and inertia is what pushes
objects down towards the earth and gives
the mere illusion of gravity so gravity
would be fake but inertia would be real
flat earthers refer to this as universal
acceleration and there's of course no
physical evidence for it none even
offered on the page about universal
acceleration on the Flat Earth Society
website here's a really simple
demonstration of the Earth's curvature
the Verrazano Bridge is a double-decker
suspension bridge in New York City and
it connects Staten Island in Brooklyn
it's two towers are four thousand two
hundred and sixty feet apart and both
towers are completely vertical and
straight and they're perpendicular with
the
beneath them but the two towers are 1.6
to 5 inches further away from one
another at the top than at the bottom
this could only be explained by Earth's
curvature here's another simple one here
at the beach and you're watching them
boat moving away from the shore over the
horizon the bottom of the boat will be
the first thing to disappear and the top
of the boat will be the last thing you
see before it completely moves to the
other side of the horizon you can also
see the curvature of the earth by simply
looking out the window of an airplane
flat earthers will tell you that there
is no actual real photo of the Earth
taken from space and that there are
merely computer generations now it is
true that most most pictures that show
the entire Earth are composite
computer-generated images different
photos of Earth taken from space which
are real have to be combined to create a
full depiction of the entire planet
because the earth is huge and you have
to get really really far away to fit the
entire planet in the frame but there are
many photos of Earth that were taken far
enough away so as to not require a
compositing such as these here which
were showing you but flat-earthers
exploit the fact that some of them are
composited to claim that they are all
fake or photoshopped as many of them
like to say and of course there are
plenty of people who have been in space
and have seen with their own eyes that
the earth is a globe and all of those
people would have to be liars many flat
earthers will say that the earth being a
globe is a lie made up to benefit space
agencies and that airlines engineers and
scientists are somehow able to keep it
covered up on a massive scale which
seems truly impossible this is not a
full list of arguments made by flat
earthers and Flat Earth or clinic claims
can very nor is it a complete list of
reasons why the earth is not flat there
are so many different ways to prove that
the earth is a globe that it's actually
difficult to know where to start
and of course flat earthers tend to have
endless fallacious comebacks - most of
these scientific claims it would be way
too much to cover in this video but I do
invite you to do your own Flat Earth
conspiracy theory research on YouTube or
elsewhere on the Internet
if you haven't already and you'll see
number one how deep the rabbit-hole goes
it can be pretty interesting but of
course you'll see that actual scientists
have rebuttals to every Flat Earth
argument so the next question is how
prevalent is this Flat Earth stuff and
who is most likely to be fooled by it
earlier this year a YouGov poll surveyed
about 8200 American adults about their
beliefs on the shape of the earth the
poll found that 2 percent of Americans
firmly believe the earth is flat and it
found that Flat Earth beliefs declined
with age the younger you are the more
likely you are to believe in Flat Earth
94% of Americans over 55 firmly believe
the earth is round the most disturbing
results were among the youngest age
range that was polled 18 to 24 in this
age range only 66 percent of respondents
say they've always believed the earth is
round 16 said they weren't sure nine
percent said they always thought the
earth was round but recently started
having doubts five percent said they
always thought the earth was flat but
recently started having doubts and four
percent they have always believed the
earth to be flat this means according to
this particular study one third of
people aged 18 to 24 are not completely
convinced that the earth is round but
Flat Earth ISM being most prevalent
among young people shouldn't really be
surprising because the revival of Flat
Earth sentiment is fairly recent and
it's fueled by the internet and social
media and several celebrities who have
come out expressing sympathy for Flat
Earth claims including internet and TV
personality Tila Tequila rapper b.o.b
Boston Celtics player Kyrie Irving and
martial artist Eddie Bravo who is well
known as a regular guest on Joe Rogan's
podcast so why is this happening now in
the age of the internet because of the
internet information dissemination is
allowed to be a lot less top-down less
hierarchical more peer-to-peer than it
has ever been before that's a good thing
in many ways people aren't turning as
often however to encyclopedias or Barnes
& Noble or the Science Channel
and instead they're going to YouTube or
online forums or Facebook for example
the US has seen a steep rise in atheism
and secularism since the year 2000
especially among young people and many
social scientists have attributed this
to the Internet people are talking to
one another about these topics and
getting more information from non
mainstream sources many of the messages
were receiving are not even ones we're
seeking out think of all the theories
and opinions you've been exposed to that
you wouldn't have otherwise if it
weren't for this ability through the
internet for everyday people to bombard
you with their ideas Facebook posts news
article comments automatic YouTube video
suggestions and all of that stuff the
world is getting smaller figuratively
and people are able to access more ideas
it's almost like a new period of
enlightenment where people are realizing
that truth doesn't have to come from
Authority or unanimity and a lot of good
can come from that that is a good thing
people can discover good and true ideas
and facts that they didn't previously
have access to but the flip side of this
or the sort of dark side of it is that
this is also making a lot of nonsense
readily available so the dissemination
of ideas like Flat Earth theories is
also speeding up undoubtedly one of the
most obvious reasons people believe in
Flat Earth is because most people don't
have a working knowledge of the science
and math that prove the earth is round
most people who are not scientists tend
to correctly trust people who are
scientists and Trust the scientific
consensus by default which is the whole
point of there being a distinction
between someone who is a scientist and
someone who's not but sometimes people
like flat earthers misunderstand what
science actually is and try to take
things into their own hands
Flat Earth theories simplify everything
and they don't require you to place your
faith in the scientific establishment
which a flat earther might perceive as
untrustworthy because of its power and
elitism the Flat Earth Society website
actually says quote the evidence for
Flat Earth is derived from many
different facets of science and
philosophy the simplest is by relying on
one's own senses to discern the true
nature of
world around us many flat earthers use
this cop-out of oh I'm just asking
questions or I just want people to find
things out for themselves they'll say do
your own research and they fail to
realize that that's not how science
works and failing to realize how many
other things they take on faith because
they know it to be true only through
experts who have done the actual work
what other established science is a lie
covered up by conspiracy the existence
of atoms photosynthesis what I am sure
draws many people into Flat Earth are
the same things that draw many people to
conspiracy theories social belonging
among other people who believe in the
conspiracy as well as a need for meaning
and control and feelings of safety in
what is admittedly a complicated and
chaotic world a desire for groundedness
some people compensate for that with
conspiracy theories and it feels good to
say that you have knowledge that most of
society lacks it's a self-esteem boost
but it's also a kind of deluded
narcissism I don't know what the right
approach is in dealing with
flat-earthers
surely presenting the real science can
be part of the solution but appeals to
Authority probably won't convince many
of them because a distrust of authority
is what got them there to begin with
others will argue we just shouldn't
ridicule flat-earthers because it will
only further alienate and embolden them
others say we should apply some social
ridicule to the ideas and the
subscribers of Flat Earth because you
want to encourage embarrassment because
it should be a source of embarrassment
in 2018 to believe that there's a Flat
Earth but in the end ignoring them may
actually be as good a solution as any
people aren't easily talked out of their
beliefs especially when reason isn't
what brought them to those beliefs in
the first place and Flat Earth isn't as
prevalent or as dangerous a scientific
conspiracy theory is something like
climate change denial for example I
don't want to tempt fate but I would
feel comfortable assuming that the Flat
Earth community will never grow beyond a
tiny marginalized group that is just a
joke to everyone else in society
prevention is the most important thing
teach science teach critical thinking
but maybe in some way we can actually be
thankful to flat-earthers
pondering and debating their arguments
is a great epistemological exercise that
can react wane to us with things that we
might take for granted like how and why
science works and what justifies a
belief on a base and fundamental level
if you want some great new ammo to use
against the flat earthers on the
internet check out an awesome new online
course offered by Caltech called the
science of the solar system or an
introduction to physics offered by the
University of Virginia you can find
these and thousands and thousands of
other classes at class - central.com
slash Pakman class central lets you take
entire college courses online from top
universities whether you're interested
in science and politics or philosophy
and psychology tens of thousands of
course is to choose from you are bound
to find something you like check it out
class - central.com slash Pakman